descendants is a disney movie series
about all the villains
accomplices and sidekicks children from
other disney movies
disney created three descendants movies
which seem to capture all of the
villains you could imagine
however there were some that they missed
to find out which villain's children
weren't in any of the descendants movies
keep watching the video
you didn't think this was the end of the
story
did you the queen of hearts child was
missing from the descendants movies
the queen of hearts is from the animated
movie alice in wonderland
the queen is married to the king of
hearts but he's less authoritative and
crazy than she is
the queen of hearts is the one who rules
the land of wonderland
according to cheshire cat if the queen
of hearts and the king of hearts had a
child he or she would probably be pale
short and plump the kid would probably
flaunt their regalness by wearing some
sort of crown and jewelry
they would definitely be wearing the
signature colors of the wonderland
monarch
red black and white with a touch of
yellow as for personality the kid would
have an
interesting upbringing with a power
hungry mother and a weak
cowardly father the child would probably
inherit a temper and be mischievous
bratty
arrogant and classy the most reasonable
explanation for why the queen
and king of wonderland's kid wasn't in
the descendants movies is because they
were grooming their child to take over
the throne
after all someone asked to take over the
land that the queen of hearts so
viciously ruled one day or maybe the
child simply couldn't find their way
out of wonderland prince hanzo's kid was
missing from the descendants movies as
well
prince hans is the 13th prince from the
southern isles kingdom
maybe the fact that prince hans was the
13th prince is why he grew up to be like
a wolf
in a sheepskin prince hans marries
princess anna with the intention of
stealing the throne from elsa
if prince hans and princess anna were to
have a child they would probably inherit
the attractive looks of their parents
however the negative influence of prince
hans would probably make the child
cunning resourceful
ambitious suave and greedy princess anna
would be a better influence
she would help the child be charming
witty and smart these aren't exactly the
descriptors of a villain
but don't get it twisted prince hans may
seem like a nice guy on the outside
but behind his kind face is a cold and
calculating man
prince hans and prince's honest child
would definitely inherit this
characteristic
their kid probably wasn't in the
descendants movies because they were
trying to build their own empire with
their sneaky
and manipulative abilities mother gothel
has a child cassandra and was the
adoptive mother of rapunzel
unfortunately cassandra was abandoned by
mother gothel when she kidnapped
rapunzel instead cassandra was raised by
the captain of the guards
cassandra didn't make an appearance in
the descendants but she isn't a villain
if mother gothel were to have another
child it's unclear who the father would
be
either way the child would likely
inherit mother gothel's thin
frame and average looks the kid would
probably have an attraction to
materialistic things and be obsessive
selfish clever and narcissistic given
mother gothel's theatrical demeanor and
history as an actress
she would be an excellent stage mom in
addition she
isn't the type of mother to stick around
unless there's something in it for her
too
this means her child would probably be
working in showbiz from a very young age
mother gothel's kid likely wasn't in the
descendants movies because they were
established in show business instead
the child probably would have some sort
of plastic surgery or appearance
enhancement to preserve their beauty
as that's the family's biggest weapon
mother gothel is guilty of abusing magic
to preserve her life and beauty
her kid would definitely do the same
ursula was in the descendants movies but
what about her sister morgana
ursula and morgana have always had
sibling rivalry which is likely why
only one of them could be in the
descendants if morgana were to have a
child they would probably look more like
a squid than an octopus
similarly to their mother morgana
doesn't have a man in her life so who
knows who the father would be
perhaps another squid or octopus
creature from the depths of the ocean
their skin would be green with unique
markings given that morgana is from an
older generation she only has streaks of
pink hair whereas her child would
probably have a full head of pink hair
morgana's child would probably have
eight tentacles too
the deep sea is a harsh place the kid
would likely become just as sadistic
sarcastic envious deceptive and evil as
their mother
because morgana was the less loved child
out of her and ursula
morgana probably wouldn't be the
greatest mother to her child
what was that you said
gizma is one of the iconic characters
from the emperor's new group
she has mothering abilities because she
raised cusco as her own
she also has two nephews zim and sam
yeezma doesn't have a husband or
boyfriend
if she were to have a child the father
would be unknown her kid would likely
acquire some sort of magic ability
because yeastma is a sorceress herself
gizma is an old woman that has a
skeletal appearance with a
sharp bone structure at one point isma
was probably beautiful and her child
could be decent looking and slim
too your child would definitely wear the
iconic purple that gizmo is always
wearing
perhaps with a touch of luxury like
their mom the kid would definitely grow
up to be mean
devious sophisticated and unforgiving
like gizma
if yizma had a child they would probably
spend a lot of time in their secret lab
hidden beneath cusco's palace
because they would be spending so much
time in the secret lab concocting
potions and
operating evil machines gizmo's child
couldn't appear on the descendants
also gizmo's secret lab was hard to find
because it had so many hidden entrances
it would be hard to find her and her kid
in peru
it's a brilliant brilliant brilliance i
tell you
sid phillips is the disturbed character
from toy story who is also a neighbor of
andy
sid was always aggressive with the toys
and was generally up to no
good in fact he often played with
explosives and chemistry
especially in relation to his toys sid
grew up to be a garbage man but we don't
know if he has a girlfriend or wife
if sid were to have a child they would
be lanky gothic and fair-skinned
the kid would probably be bratty violent
sadistic entitled and a delinquent as
well
the child would likely be an introvert
as well and spend lots of time playing
video games and listening to hardcore
music
if sid had more than one child they
would definitely torment each other just
like sid used to torment his sister
hannah
sid lives in a normal human world he
isn't aware of the other worlds
the only thing syd knows is that toys
are alive
for this reason his child likely didn't
appear in the descendants because they
were lost
in the regular world in pocahontas
governor ratcliffe was a colonizer that
terrorized communities to gain power and
respect in britain
governor ratcliffe doesn't have a known
wife or girlfriend but if he were to
have a child they would be fat
have long hair and pale skin the
governor from pocahontas is known to be
obnoxious in pompous which shows by the
way he dresses
his child would probably dress in a
preppy manner too
likely with some sort of bling or bright
color governor ratcliffe's child would
definitely be greedy
disrespectful unempathetic rude and cold
like their father
his child would also have an english
accent given that governor ratcliffe is
from
england governor ratcliffe's goal was to
colonize and take gold from the land
he wanted more than ever to be well
respected in his community in england
although governor ratcliffe failed
because of his greed he was eventually
arrested for his treason crimes
this work ethic would probably be passed
on to his child
for this reason his kid probably wasn't
in the descendants movies because he was
engaging in his own colonizations
raised in a house of power wealth greed
and supremacy
there's no way his child wouldn't engage
in the same activity
as his father and it came so highly
recommended
syndrome or rather buddy wasn't always a
bad guy
my name is not buddy his goal was
originally to become the sidekick of mr
incredible
when syndrome was rejected he became sad
and upset
because the righteous path didn't work
out for him syndrome became evil
and made it his goal to eliminate all
superheroes so that he could have all
the fame and glory to himself
syndrome is literally a genius which is
precisely what made him such a great
opponent to mr incredible
before his villainous plan syndrome was
a child prodigy that was particularly
talented in technology engineering
syndrome doesn't appear to have a wife
or girlfriend but that doesn't mean he
couldn't have a kid
his child would probably be
exceptionally smart like him
in addition to being witty arrogant
dishonest inventive and cruel
syndrome's child would probably possess
some sort of superpower as well
similarly to the other characters from
the incredibles because syndrome was a
failed villain his child probably wasn't
worthy of being on the descendants
it's also possible that syndrome's kid
took the academic route and is in school
instead of being a villain meta medusa's
child
didn't appear on the descendants she's
from an older movie called the rescuers
madame medusa is an obsessive and
materialistic person
this becomes obvious when it's portrayed
that she's obsessed with diamonds in her
pawn
shop she likely doesn't have a spouse
because of her ugly appearance
she has a thin frame with a pot belly
yet she doesn't seem to realize that she
doesn't have a pleasant appearance
unfortunately if she had a child they
would likely inherit her hideous looks
similarly to madame medusa the kid might
try to improve their appearance through
makeup
dress and other physical appearance
changes her child would probably be
greedy
sneaky persuasive selfish and sinister
like their mom
madame medusa's kid probably never
appeared in the descendants
because she was too busy operating her
pawn shop with her child
in fact they were probably on a journey
to find more diamonds since
that's madame medusa's prime obsession
and passion
she was certainly an evil character but
she enjoyed her diamonds the most
maybe her child would have an obsession
too maybe gold
valuable coins or rare art finally we
have shan yu
and his supposed child shanyu is the
evil leader
of the hun army in mulan like many
powerful leaders
shanyun is ruthless powerful cunning and
condescending
his child would probably inherit these
attributes in addition to being
manipulative
and aggressive his child would likely
look similar to their father with a bold
frame
lots of muscle yellow eyes and dark hair
because of shanyu's military background
his child
would probably undergo some sort of
formal training chanyu would definitely
want to prepare
any child he had for battle his child
might even develop some sort of special
ability as shan yu had super human
strength
it was always his goal to conquer china
he failed before but he is likely
rebuilding his army and using his child
to become
even more powerful this is probably why
shandy's child never appeared
in the descendants i tire of your
arrogance old man
bow to me those are all the villain
children from the disney films that
never appeared in the descendants movies
who knows maybe disney will create a
fourth descendants movie with all these
children
if you enjoyed this video hit that like
button and don't forget to subscribe to
the things if you want to see similar
content